Traduttore: Asia Carafa
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Abbiamo sentito un po'
di storie di successo:
io vi parlo un po' di fallimenti, invece.
Cinque mesi fa,
una rivista di viaggi americana
con cui stavo collaborando
mi commissiona un articolo
su come viaggiare lungo la via della seta
senza prendere aerei.
Questa breve guida,
neanche troppo approfondita,
spiegava come arrivare
da Chiang in Cina a Istanbul in Turchia
passando attraverso l'Asia centrale:
un viaggio che avevo fatto
qualche anno fa.
Per me è una piccola soddisfazione
riuscire a parlare dei posti
e degli argomenti che avevo a cuore
su una rivista internazionale,
nella mia seconda lingua;
però considerando che per essere in grado
di pubblicare questo articolo
ci avevo messo nove anni,
i 60 dollari che mi davano
non erano così tanti.
(Risate)
Comunque accetto.
Quattro mesi fa
vengo contattato dall'editore
di una piccola guida all'Asia centrale,
che avevo usato tra l'altro
nei miei viaggi,
per complimentarsi con quanto
avevo scritto nell'articolo precedente.
Dopo un breve scambio di email,
questo editore mi chiede
se io per caso mi trovassi in zona,
e con zona intendeva Kazakistan
(Risate)
e se per caso avessi intenzione
di collaborare insieme a lui
ad aggiornare le sue guide.
Io non mi trovavo in zona:
abito in Olanda.
Non avevo intenzione di andarci,
ma rispondo: "Sì, sarò lì a breve;
e sì, sono interessato a collaborare".
Quindi, tre mesi fa
compro un biglietto per il Kazakistan,
poco dopo parto e di questo lavoro
non ne viene fuori niente.
Però, mentre stavo andando in Kazakistan
un contatto di un'altra rivista mi chiede,
mi fa capire che c'era la possibilità
di pubblicare un articolo
sul lago di Aral.
Quindi io arrivo a Almaty,
prendo 25 ore di treno
per andare sul lago di Aral,
che come vedete non è molto ospitale.
(Risate)
Sto lì un giorno o due
e poi prendo 25 ore di treno
per tornare indietro.
E poi, anche di quel lavoro
non se ne fa niente.
(Risate)
Io, già che ero in Asia,
proseguo il mio viaggio.
E quindi scendo in Uzbekistan,
e poi arrivo in Tagikistan.
Dal Tagikistan entro in Kirghistan,
che era un po' l'ultima tappa
del mio viaggio;
e in Kirghistan divento la guida
di un gruppo di sette semi-sconosciuti
che avevano risposto ad un mio annuncio
sulla mia pagina Facebook
e hanno deciso di venire.
Questi sono loro che hanno scoperto
di dover camminare
per 1300 metri di dislivello.
E l'hanno scoperto
perché non lo sapevo neanche io.
(Risate)
(Applausi)
Quindi: due settimane fa
sono in Kirghistan;
una settimana fa sono ad Amsterdam
a cominciare un Master in Studi Letterari;
e oggi sono qui, al TEDx, a Empoli.
Ora, chi sente questa storia,
di solito tende a pensare
che una persona come me,
per avere esperienze così specifiche,
debba necessariamente avere un'idea chiara
di quello che vuole dalla vita,
o almeno della direzione da prendere.
Forse qualcuno avrà capito che non è così,
e se mi aveste chiesto sei mesi fa
cosa sarebbe successo fino ad oggi
io non sarei stato in grado di rispondere
su nessuna delle cose
che vi ho raccontato.
Questo però non è un caso,
questo succede perché io,
da più o meno dieci anni,
ho investito molte energie
nel cercare di costruire uno stile di vita
che mi permettesse
di fare scelte sbagliate
o, nel migliore dei casi,
di non scegliere affatto.
(Risate)
E quello di cui vi vorrei parlare oggi
è appunto di libera scelta,
e di come questo influenzi il modo
in cui vediamo noi stessi
e la nostra identità.
In adolescenza, prima di partire,
soffrivo un po' l'idea
che la mia identità fosse il prodotto
di tutto quello che la società
in cui vivevo mi aveva dato in pasto.
Mi sembrava di non essermi
costruito da solo.
Da una parte, mi rendevo conto
che la mia generazione ha più opportunità
di chiunque altro in passato;
dall'altra parte non riuscivo a capire
come mai le vite che vedevo
evolversi attorno a me
fossero tutte così simili.
In qualche modo avevo paura
che se avessi seguito
questo percorso comune
mi sarei perso qualcosa:
mi sembrava un modo pigro di vivere.
Oggi credo di essere stato
invitato qui per questo motivo:
io nella mia vita lavoro da 12-13 anni,
non ho mai passato un giorno
imbottigliato nel traffico.
Ho invece risposto
a questo dubbio esistenziale,
che penso tutti abbiano avuto
a un punto o l'altro della loro vita,
partendo per un viaggio molto lungo.
A gennaio 2010 compro
un biglietto per l'Australia
con l'idea di partire
da una pagina bianca:
il mio obiettivo più grande, nella vita,
era appunto arrivare
e non sapere cosa trovare,
vedere e scontrarmi con i miei limiti
per conoscere me stesso.
Quindi io parto senza un telefono,
senza un computer,
senza un posto dove dormire la prima sera,
con l'idea di darmi sei mesi
per vedere dove sarei arrivato,
per conoscere sia le mie potenzialità
ma anche i miei limiti.
Quel viaggio di sei mesi
è durato cinque anni.
Sono tornato a casa
per la prima volta dopo cinque anni,
ma comunque oggi ne sono passati dieci
e ancora va avanti.
Dopo aver vissuto un anno in Australia
e due anni in Nuova Zelanda,
decido di fare il passo
più lungo della gamba,
e cercare di tornare in Europa
senza prendere aerei,
attraversando l'Asia.
Quindi prendo un volo per Timor Est,
e da lì inizia un viaggio
che anche lì doveva durare sei mesi,
ed è durato due anni.
Durante questo viaggio
incontro tante persone,
e le mie idee iniziano a cambiare
su quello che volevo
e sui miei obbiettivi nella vita.
Inizio a sentire
una narrativa che si ripete,
storie sempre simili
di persone con vite completamente diverse
di quelle che io avevo visto a casa mia.
E infatti, di storie come la mia
ce ne sono tantissime:
se andate su Internet
ne trovate quante ne volete,
di gente che parte, non torna
o sta via per tantissimo tempo,
ci sono anche delle TEDtalk a riguardo.
E a me piacerebbe essere qui a dirvi
che la mia vita è migliore della vostra
o che la strada alternativa
è un'idea giusta per tutti;
però non è proprio così.
Questa narrativa del
"mollare tutto e partire"
del prendere coraggio
e prendere responsabilità
della propria vita
non dipende sempre da una scelta.
Per me, chiaramente,
questo è stato benefico,
e se tornassi indietro
rifarei tutto da capo.
La realtà è che in dieci anni
trascorsi tra Europa, Asia e Oceania
mi sono accorto che la via alternativa
non è poi così alternativa.
Ci sono due cose,
in particolare, che ho notato:
la prima è che chi va a star bene -
o chi va a star meglio,
perché questo è l'obbiettivo di chi parte
per viaggi ad un lungo termine,
è quasi sempre chi già sta molto bene.
La seconda cosa
è che quando partiamo,
e viaggiamo per mesi e mesi,
finiamo tutti per fare la stessa cosa.
Vi faccio un esempio:
questo posto io non sarei
in grado di dirvi dov'è,
non saprei trovarlo:
questo è in Asia centrale,
è su una montagna a 3000 metri di altezza,
e questo simboleggiava un po'
il picco della mia idea di libertà:
io ero arrivato in un posto
con persone che avevo appena conosciuto,
che potevo chiamare mio perché non c'era
neanche un sentiero per arrivarci.
Questa foto in qualche modo, per me,
è diventata un simbolo, al tempo,
di questa mia ricerca di libertà,
finché non sono tornato a casa -
(Risate)
e ho scoperto questo account di Instagram,
che si chiama "Insta Repeat",
che come vedete raccoglie
la ripetizione costante di immagini
che noi crediamo uniche,
ma che in verità fanno parte
di un immaginario collettivo
che non è poi così alternativo.
Qui c'è qualche altro esempio.
Facciamo tutti le stesse cose:
non so bene quale sia il messaggio
da cogliere da queste immagini,
però la nostra idea di libera scelta,
e forse anche di meritocrazia,
va un po' rivalutata secondo me.
Non esiste nessuna pagina bianca
da cui cominciare,
subiamo sempre delle influenze esterne
che ci spingono in direzioni simili.
E questo non è un problema,
perché poi le emozioni personali,
quando uno finisce in uno di questi posti,
hanno lo stesso valore.
Il valore non cambia, ecco.
Il problema è quando ci identifichiamo
nelle nostre scelte,
e soprattutto nei nostri successi,
senza tenere conto
del privilegio, o dell'influenza,
che ci ha portato fino a quel traguardo.
Io sono cresciuto abbastanza
con il mito dell'uomo che si fa da sé,
e ho sempre ammirato le persone
che sacrificano tutto:
oggi abbiamo sentito
tante storie di successo
di persone che raggiungono
obiettivi elevati
con quelle che pensavo
fossero le proprie forze.
Mi sono accorto, col tempo,
che io non sono quello che faccio.
E che puntare dritto
verso un punto di arrivo
non solo appiattiva la mia vita
ma poteva essere causa
di frustrazione e rancore.
Io in viaggio ho incontrato tante persone
impegnate in imprese notevoli:
c'era chi faceva il giro
del mondo in bicicletta,
chi faceva il giro del mondo a piedi,
chi scala montagne,
chi colleziona montagne
e trova la propria dimensione
in queste vette.
Anch'io, nel mio piccolo,
speravo di trovare la mia dimensione
in questo lungo viaggio attraverso l'Asia;
però, a un certo punto,
mi sono reso conto
che tra queste esperienze,
che qualcuno può considerare estreme,
e che poi magari tanto estreme non sono,
e chi cerca magari la propria identità
in una carriera o in un percorso
comunque tradizionale
non c'è così tanta differenza.
Il problema principale
dell'identificarsi nei propri successi
è che tutto quello che si mette in mezzo
tra noi e il punto d'arrivo
diventa un ostacolo,
incluse le persone che per un motivo
o un altro si muovono a ritmi diversi,
che vanno più piano o rimangono indietro.
Io non sono quello che faccio:
piuttosto, ho notato che io sono
le storie che racconto.
Le storie più belle, però,
sono quelle che io
non ho mai pianificato in anticipo:
mi sono sempre successe per caso.
Negli anni,
ed è per questo che io ho tentato
di costruire uno stile di vita
che permettesse
agli imprevisti di accadere,
ho cercato di fare "un piano di vita
per una vita senza piani".
Ho ridotto nella pratica
i miei possedimenti al minimo:
io non ho una casa mia,
non ho una macchina,
non ho bollette,
non ho debiti, non ho rate.
Ho spostato il mio lavoro su Internet:
io non sono legato ad un posto fisico,
se una porta si apre
io mi muovo senza nessun problema,
come oggi qui.
Continuo a viaggiare abbastanza spesso:
ma anche i viaggi non li pianifico,
io vado un po' a caso
e tendo sempre a tornare
negli stessi posti adesso,
non ho più l'interesse
ad attaccare bandierine allo zaino.
Il mio quindi, qui,
non è un invito a partire,
perché non è per tutti
e non tutti possono farlo.
E questo va riconosciuto, sia chiaro.
Piuttosto, è un invito
ad accogliere il nuovo
e a fare meno affidamento
a piani a lungo termine
che vi spingono a vivere
col pilota automatico.
Nel mio caso ci sono stati
dei risultati tangibili:
ad esempio io mi arrabbio molto poco
per i piccoli ostacoli
che mi si mettono di fronte.
Ma mi sveglio la mattina, anche,
con un senso di responsabilità
che è molto più elevato
di come lo era in passato.
Le decisioni le devo prendere ogni giorno,
perché non so quello
che mi potrebbe accadere.
E questo dà una profondità alla mia vita
che prima non avevo.
Il motivo per cui sono qui
a raccontarvi questa storia, però,
non è perché lo dobbiate fare anche voi:
è perché secondo me
ci siamo identificati troppo
nel punto di arrivo,
e quindi si è andato a perdere
un senso di vicinanza
per chi commette errori
e per chi magari, per qualche motivo,
non riesce a giocare
allo stesso gioco
che siamo abituati a giocare.
Io vi invito quindi, invece di viaggiare,
a rendervi vulnerabili,
abbandonando questa necessità
della scelta giusta a tutti i costi.
E a uscire da questo affanno
del diventare,
provocando un'empatia che spesso
è più utile di qualsiasi traguardo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)